[Musique]
aujourd'hui 6 janvier en fête
l'épiphanie
en mangeant la galette dayraut monsieur
quelle est l'origine de la fête
l'épiphanie
ce n'est pas moi sur parole
alors là
j'ai perdu les pédales benoît
véritablement qu'une somme
j'ai vu ça écrit sur le calendrier mais
je sais pas exactement ce que c'est que
cette histoire
nice est une fête les roma je crois
enfin une fête de l'évangile la fête de
l'épiphanie m'a pas je peux pas vous
dire parce que je suis pas très
catholique je te connais absolument rien
les
marchands des allergies la fête des rois
qu'est ce que c'est pour vous
je vois pas trop
je suis venu j'en profite je l'avais
juste mais je l'épiphanie c'est la fête
des rois pour il ne sait pas exactement
à moins que ce soit ces très vieux pour
évidemment il faudra qu'on mange la
galette
sera là
pourquoi moi je le regrette je suis
pareil japon de bonheur je sais pas sur
quelle est l'origine de la fête de
l'épiphanie ou alors ça l'épiphanie
c'est pas du sellier la mort de richesse
[Musique]